mar 10 go de mémoire mardi on a mis ses
surplus de 10 tonnes de bois scoop dit
on plus donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on fait appel aux médias parce
que pour liquider le poisson au maximum
au maximum parce que il y en a il y en a
une pêche miraculeuse si la branche est
là mais l'univers culoz puisque jusqu'à
maintenant elle est dans l'eau est
légalement puisque on la part qui ont la
partie donc elle est prise au piège là
donc elle est mieux à culoz elle peut
pas partir là un système de deux pas
aquatique l'élevage des poissons est ce
qu'on appelle les cubis système pour
mettre le boisson locale comme on
appelle les colis ou en cache celio
c'est pour donner plus de qualité